you
whether you love it hate it or have
never thought about it chances are some
nanny wants to ban it presenting the
nanny of the month runners-up the FDA
for embarking on a year-long sting
operation to bust an Amish company for
selling raw milk and the New York
Department of Health activities like
wiffle ball and kickball and dodge ball
and capture the flag would be considered
to have quote significant risk to injury
officials were poised to slap tough new
regulations on summer camps that offered
such games until a public outcry made
them back off but there can be only one
Danny of a month in this time it's also
Carmona principal of the little village
Academy while in public school in
Chicago is actually banning kids from
bringing their lunch from home but away
those lunchboxes kids unless you've got
a medical excuse to eat whatever the
cafeteria is serving or go hungry Ramona
says she's protecting kids from
unhealthy habits there's only one winner
in this situation that's the company
that provides the food and serving kids
at school lunch is one thing getting
them to eat it is another one seventh
grader even held a lunchtime rebellion
making the kids chant over and over we
should bring our lunch we should bring
our lunch check back next month for more
examples busybodies money your own
business